I've come together with the one on my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter bone sisters helped to feed those
who are in poor conditions and who don't
even have a clothing to keep theirself
warm your small donation might mean
nothing to you but it can change their
life and help them survive the winter
this year
brothers and sisters and dear friends
true Geordie he made a comment what was
that comment that he's having a feud
with our brother Andrew Tate there's not
many people in the world that have a
personal beef with
I've had some internet beefs back and
forth there's very few people I
personally dislike one of them is true
Geordie anyone who's followed me long
enough understands why he's a very
insulting fat vulgar he's a he's an
unlikable person he's not very smart and
now after me converting to Islam he made
a piece on one of his podcasts saying
that I'm not true in my conversion and
then insulted all Muslims then the
Muslims blow themselves up and I should
go blow myself up we should all blow
ourselves up let me tell you something
my friend and if true Jordan if you're
watching this this is a message directly
to you
there are certain times in life you need
to know when to [ __ ] up there are
certain things which are not funny
certain things are not Beyond reprisal
you don't sit and insult a man's
religion just like you don't insult a
man's entire company and the people who
work for him that's one thing but to
insult my religion
and the religion of billions of people
across the planet making ignorant jokes
about blowing ourselves up thinking
that's going to go without consequence
you're going to learn very quickly my
friend that that was a mistake and he's
going back and forth so he decided to on
a live stream to say that if Andrew Tate
our Muslim brother is a true Muslim he
should go and blow himself up are you
fighting Andrew too although I would
gladly blow myself up if I could take
that [ __ ] bag with us
um that's the use of a stereotype there
which is obviously not what he uh I'm
just saying if he really wants to prove
it do the right thing now when someone
says this what comes to your mind I'll
be honest it'd be good you know somebody
who's in Islamic and for him for him to
say that on a live platform just
randomly to me shows his Prejudice and
how he views us Muslims I mean I didn't
really I was quite surprised when he
said that why because I've spoken to
Jordi I've spoken to him a couple of
years ago when I was after Tommy
Robinson the coward and I finally
tracked him down and exposed his food
and his lies
um which some of them should draw the
some of the sentiments Tommy Robinson
shares it looks like seems like true
Jordi also does did he mean it did he
not mean it his apology video came out
did he apologize because his YouTube
career was on the line did he apologize
because he was genuine we cannot see the
heart as the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him told us that weak judge from us
apparent of course we shouldn't be fools
but for him to say that truly did hurt
me to an extent because he did reach out
to me once and invited me and Tommy
Robinson to discuss this matter and if
we maybe did that maybe he would have
never say such things he would have
learned and be educated in a polite
manner what we Muslims believe and this
whole notion of us blowing ourselves up
um you know it's not true it's a big fat
lie you know as good as me coming and
accusing true Jordi of being a pedophile
because for some reason his age you know
or his prayer it comes from a white uh a
Caucasian background his middle age you
know white guy and I could have easily
you know make that statement you know
because he meets the profile of Those
who commit these hineous acts but of
course it's I'm not planning on doing
this I'm just giving you guys an example
now our brother Andrew Tate there was
times before he was a Muslim which he
was spewing certain things that Islam
and the Sharia called us to refute him
on those matters and I've even used
words as calling Andrew Tay I would
rather before he came to Islam a no
value man I didn't do this because I was
anything person against him so when the
Sharia calls us to warn against somebody
or refute somebody we do as what the
Sharia tells us not our own ego not to
me not liking or whatever reason it may
be there should not be person against
that however since he came to Islam I
took that video down yes and since
that's the case and is repented and now
he's our brother in the religion and
some somebody else is now attacking him
means he's attacking us so what that
means in a nutshell brothers and sisters
when the Sharia calls us to defend we
defend when the Sharia calls us to
expose we expose we're at the stage
where our brother entertainers accepted
Islam and we will defend his honor and
not only his honor but the honor of the
Muslims at large now I was going to do
this video going on a bit of a rampage
with true jewelry but then I took a step
back I spoke to a couple of Brothers
brother Ben on a group and a few other
brothers and they said look
some people make mistakes we all do and
we believe in Islam that everybody sins
and the best of Sinners are those who
repent now children I as far as I know
you're an atheist I know you live in the
UK and I would like to reach out to you
I'll be honest with you I was actually
planning on confronting you I'll be very
honest with you just as Tommy Robinson I
was planning on literally first calling
you out for a debate and then after that
if you refuse to actually confront you
he has to track you down and confront
you and I don't mean this in a way of
being childish but just to for an
academic intellectual discussion for the
statements that you set but you've done
a video apologizing I don't think we
need to go there let's move on from that
I think it's best that we move on from
that and we as Muslims we tend to be
forgiven for those who wrong us so
therefore true Jordi if you are up for
it I don't want any media platform I
don't want any
um attention I'm not doing this for
clout I don't want nothing genuinely if
you are up for it myself I'm at the job
and whoever you would like would like to
take you out for a date to a mosque we
can come to a local mosque near you you
can come to London to us if you like and
let's arrange this and come to some
understanding and maybe like you saw
Andrew take Andrew Tate in back in the
days made some islamophobic comments but
like we said God Almighty guides people
and he changes the hearts I'm not gonna
carry this on for too long brothers and
sisters but what I'm going to say in a
nutshell is this we are reaching our
hands out to True Jordi because I
genuinely believe he may be in a place
where his loss is an atheist and I want
to give him this reminder from the Quran
that maybe reflects and I would like to
further have this with him in person
without cameras if he wants to record it
he can but genuinely we just want to
show him the true side of Islam which
our brother Andrew Tate saw that made
him Embrace Allah says in the Quran
how is it that you deny Allah while you
were lifeless and he gave you life then
he will make you die and then he will
make you live again and then to him
you'll be returned as an atheist you
believe and if you believe this at one
moment of time you was in non-existence
you was dead if you think about it in
that sense you was dead and then you was
born
so God Almighty is making you think and
saying was you not dead at one moment
and you came back to life I mean well
you came to life and Allah is telling us
God Almighty that you will once again
die just how you was dead before and
once again he will bring you back to
life and your final return is to him our
purpose in this life is greater then
whatever you want to do and like I said
our brother Andrew Taylor is a fine
example he has all those luxuries but he
realized that only in the remembrance of
his Lord those hearts find peace I hope
you reflect on that verse and understand
that we will return back to our Lord and
we definitely do have a purpose just as
my camera does just as the chair I'm
sitting on just as the lighting and this
mic they don't have a purpose you also
have a purpose please reach out to us if
you would like to you don't have to like
I said before and I would like to talk
to you more about Islam and tell you
about what our religion teaches and
maybe you have some misconceptions I'll
leave out that until next time brothers
and sisters please send us the true
Jordi and hope he watches it and changes
his heart and you never know once
enemies true Jordi and Andrew Tate yeah
might become friends in Islam like
myself I was never an enemy to Andrew
Tate but there was things that he'd done
which I had to warn against now he's our
brother we Embrace him fully and we
forget like it never happened and we and
he's probably better than myself and you
know many people may Allah keep him firm
till next time